hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it is december 8th 2021 we are
live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv and my only request of you
today is to subscribe to our rumble
channel okay there you go
uh we got a packed show for you today
it's a little all over the place and we
added video clips in the last second and
i have a feeling i'm going on the record
right up top today that this is going to
be one of the best
shows one of the best most complete
programs we've ever done because not
only are the topics good not only am i
caffeinated i feel good life's been good
lately i've got a couple big
announcements coming but also today
the reuben report team are all getting
their reviews
and they're being made aware of raises
and bonuses so the two gentlemen that
are in this studio they know their
futures depend on what happens today
because i could change the numbers i
could move a comma i could move a period
fire people all together so everybody
we're on edge you can feel it in here a
pin could drop
and i sense this is going to be
the most perfect reuben report
ever
the four topics today first off elon
musk you know elon musk founder of tesla
spacex whole bunch of other stuff
co-founder of paypal that's really what
put him on the map originally uh he was
doing an interview with wall street
journal and he just basically torched
joe biden and just wrecked the entire
build back better agenda and the whole
freaking thing so we got a couple clips
of him it's just spectacular although i
am wondering what's going on with his
hair we'll talk about that uh second uh
we talked about this yesterday it was
breaking just as we went live yesterday
but a federal judge has stopped joe
biden's unconstitutional vaccine
mandates for federal workers what
happened a little bit after we did our
live stream yesterday was jen saki was
asked about that and she man i don't
like that woman she's just terrible and
basically said we don't care what the
courts say so we could have a real
constitutional battle here which i'm in
the mood for
and then fauci has been all over uh the
media last day or two again you know
they trot him out
usually on sundays but he did a whole
bunch of shows yesterday and he's
basically saying he doesn't care about
individual choice that you better submit
and uh i don't know if he's ever read
the constitution but that's not how it
works and i'm going to fight you to the
bitter end
fraudshi that's what i'm going to call
you for now on fragi uh the third story
is that a robert e lee statue in
charlottesville virginia is going to be
melted and turned into some sort of
social justice statute you can only
imagine how horrible that's going to be
and we're going to show you some video
of
what happened back in charlottesville
charlottesville which of course led to
so much of the nonsense we've been
dealing with for the last couple years
and the way the media framed it and the
lies about trump very fine people on
both sides and how joe biden actually
launched his campaign with a lie we're
gonna show you a video we've got
videotape uh and then finally you know
yesterday we ended the show with that
really incredible video
of the 92 year old holocaust survivor
who had survived auschwitz uh talking
about sort of the creep of what happens
in an authoritarian regime how you
dehumanize people you take away little
things don't sit on this bench don't get
on that bus you can't go into that store
how it happens very slowly that nazis
and authoritarians and the worst people
who want to do horrible things to others
they don't just appear overnight right
like it's a slow creep much like what
we've
all been going through for the last two
years there's just been it's it's so
different from two weeks to flatten the
curve and herd immunity to now don't get
on planes or trains if you're not
vaccinated wear a mess river and
everything else well i saw a clip uh
which is a couple years old of jordan
peterson on joe rogan's show talking
about that very psychological notion
that how you move people you move them
slowly so we're going to show you that
clip with a little bit uh just a 30
second
bite of the the chat from the holocaust
survivor and and thank you guys you know
i put that up yesterday and i didn't
know how people were going to feel about
it because it's obviously it's quite
heavy and i didn't feel that i had to do
much analysis of it we just sort of let
it be there and then i asked that
question at the end you know what are
you going to do
but a lot of people really do like that
it gets us a little bit out of just the
the day-to-day political lunacy and sort
of shows the bigger ideas that are going
on here so that is the show today and
before i get to any of that i want to
talk to you guys about bonner private
wine people i've got a bottle of malbec
in my hands right now do you have a hard
time choosing the best christmas wines
to serve you know that moment at the
liquor store when you're standing in
front of the display going through your
menu trying to remember what your guests
like to drink last year make christmas
special people with the extreme altitude
wine from bonner private wines they are
wines unlike anything you've ever tasted
blackberry leather smoke and a little
dark cherry imagine pouring a glass for
your christmas dinner simply perfection
it's also healthier than other wines
with 10 times more resveratrol and 90
less sugar no dyes no flavor additives
bonner private wines are bringing these
rare wines to americans for the holiday
season to enjoy with your family and
friends or to give us a special gift
that can't be found in stores we busted
open a couple bottles during
thanksgiving and i got a lot of
compliments i kid you not visit
bonnerprivetwines.com
dave and you'll get top quality extreme
altitude wine for about half the price
no need for a promo code hurry the
shipping deadline for christmas delivery
is december 15th bonner privatewines.com
dave that's bonner privatewines.com
dave and now back to me
all right let's jump right into it so
elon musk was doing a talk with a wall
street journal reporter we've got two
separate clips here and man oh man did
he lay down some truth clip number one
you know at some point really what
you're doing is capital allocation so
you're not it's not money for personal
expenditures it's what you're doing is
capital allocation and it does not make
sense to take uh the the job of capital
allocation away from people who have
demonstrated great skill in capital
allocation and give it to
uh
you know an entity that has demonstrated
very poor skill in in capital allocation
which is the government
i mean you can think of the government
essentially uh as a corporation in the
limit
it is it is a the government is simply
the biggest corporation with a monopoly
on violence
and with and where you have no recourse
so how much money you want to give that
entity
so basically what elon's saying there is
the government ain't good at much we
always give it more and more money right
every year it wants more of our tax
money it wants more control over us but
what does the government do really well
i mean he's given you sort of a lot of
libertarian 101 there the quote was
government is simply the biggest
corporation with the sole monopoly on
violence meaning amazon is a corporation
they can't arrest you yet
soon enough they'll send drones to your
house that'll just take you out or just
blow you up but one thing at a time here
you know what i mean um but the
government can basically say to you hey
we want more of your money we want 50
of what you earn oh you're doing well
we're going to take more of your money
oh we see you've made a good investment
well we're going to punish you for that
etc etc and then what are they doing
with the money usually they're putting
it into government programs that are
usually just band-aids on other things
that the government screwed up so just
think about it in your life like right
now as a citizen of the united states or
even think about it for our
international viewers whatever country
you're in right now i'll talk to the
canadians specifically the canadians who
are up there who can no longer get on
trains or planes or leave their country
if they're unvaccinated it's like what
is your government doing really well
right it's making sure that you don't
drive over a bridge to infect somebody
with a disease you don't have
the government is constantly putting
money into programs that end up keeping
more people on welfare and turn it into
a cyclical thing over generations and
people don't get out of poverty because
the government keeps them on the lowest
possible sustainable level um we all
know all of this and yet
if you listen to mainstream media and
you listen to democrat politicians oh if
the rich only paid their fair share now
the rich pay most of the taxes everyone
knows all that but they just keep lying
it just never ends but it's like okay if
the rich only paid their fair share so
let's say the government had i don't
know let's say the government had an
extra 20 billion
you know what i'm feeling generous this
morning it's the holiday season let's
say the government had an extra trillion
dollars trillion dollars now we know
that 3.5 trillion dollars equals zero
according to the democrats but let's say
you just magically gave the government
extra trillion does anyone think
anything would be better
do you honestly think anything would be
better would that do anything on top of
the fact that we don't even have any
money in the first place we run on
massive deficits so the issue with
government is that government should be
cut we should be scaling back government
i'm sorry a lot of people that have
middle management bureaucratic
nonsensical jobs should have to get
other jobs should have to figure out
other things to do we have to cut the
federal government's budget we should
cut the department of education we could
go through a whole bunch of departments
that could probably be cut i would be i
would right now you just said to me dave
you're in charge cut everything by 20
25 across the board cut everything
everything defense the whole freaking
thing and guess what what would happen
is the government would be a little
slimmer a little trimmer it would most
likely operate better and also this idea
that the democrats are always pushing
and it's partly with this buildback
better thing of you know everyone will
have a guarantee for a job and you'll
have government jobs it's like who wants
a government job like a government job
does that sound like what your dream is
the purpose of being a human is to find
what your dream is find what your
passion is and go get it not just be
part of the machine and give your life
and your money and your existence and
your passion and everything else to the
machine man no it ain't well elon musk
went on and he specifically talked about
biden's build back better agenda all
right but oh there's there's some other
good things in this bill that some would
argue i mean a lot of money earmarked
for r d
would you want to put that towards
something
no
okay
all right all right we're going to move
on from the bill because i think
we get what you're seriously saying
in general we should just we if we don't
cut government spending the
something really bad is going to happen
this is crazy our spending is so far in
excess of revenue it's insane
um
like you could zero out all billionaires
in the country this is almost like
anti-billionaire bs well uh if you
zeroed out all the billionaires you
still wouldn't solve the deficit
all right there's there's a lot there um
first off i don't know exactly what's
going on with his hair i feel like i
just have to address it something but
you know he's going for that kid look
you she's real tight on the side that
you get the thing up above okay fine
that's fine um
in essence he's saying we don't have
money for this stuff you know what he
said there at the end this thing about
the billionaires you know elizabeth
warren and bernie they're always
attacking the billionaires these people
who create things much like elon musk
like think how much more
value elon musk has brought to the world
than
elizabeth warren than bernie sanders
right like this guy is literally sending
rockets into space he's building
underground tunnels here in los angeles
to start uh to start you know trains so
that we can avoid traffic the guy put a
tesla in space just for the hell of it
he's doing all of this stuff if you've
never driven in a tesla it's the coolest
freaking thing ever you feel like you're
in the future you feel like you're in
one of those cars from minority report
like the guy is doing so much he does it
within the confines of what the
government allows so if the government
has you know uh green tax credits and
that helps him he uses them you know
what i mean but this this idea that we
should just demonize the billionaires
it's like i would much rather
live in a world that someone like elon
musk was influencing public policy than
a fake indian like elizabeth warren or
an old bitter socialist like bernie
sanders they've never created a job
they've never created anything so we can
demonize the billionaires all we want
and we can talk about
some level of taxing them a little bit
more like we can talk about all of that
stuff i'm not even really for it for me
like you can read it in my book it's
right over my shoulder like i believe in
a flat tax and you could you could allow
the lowest people to pay nothing and if
you're at the top you could pay a tiny
bit more but basically i'd have a system
where 90 of us pay the same exact rate
we can discuss whether that's 17 or 21
or whatever but like just cut everything
the government ain't good at jack [ __ ]
but the the idea that we're just gonna
demonize the hell out of the people who
produce who make things happen who send
cars into space who do all of the cool
stuff who build tech who build phones
but those are the bad guys so i like
seeing somebody uh awake and you know
not woke but awake right like he's
really he's saying hey just get out of
our way and by the way this is a guy who
puts his money where his mouth is he
took tesla from the dystopian uh
overreaching authoritarian state of
california what did he do he moved them
to texas he moved them to texas and
they're going to flourish there
obviously and that's a beautiful thing
and michael bought a tesla yesterday can
i say that i can say that michael bought
a tesla that's right you want to work at
the reuben report i know you do the
performance model y wow perform it i
gotta review this review with you uh all
right let's move on uh guys call it
climate change or just call it winter
it's cold out can you ever have enough
socks in the winter not really you can't
but instead of throwing a pack of crew
socks into your cart grab a few of these
100
american-made and patriotic socks these
socks are unlike any on the market and
because of their special messaging
they'll surely put a spring in your step
the let's go brandon message has united
americans in a way our current
administration never imagined but it
gets even better because of the
production of these socks helps fund
1200
that's 1 200 american jobs not to be
confused with china so not only will
these socks warm your feet they'll also
warm your heart these socks are special
and limited edition available for a
short time so pre-order now if you want
to commemorate the reason for the let's
go brandon broken supply chain season
act now these historical toe steppers
are only available for a limited time
available for purchase now through the
end of 2021 but once they are gone they
are gone for good let's celebrate
christmas in patriotic style and dance
the night away snatch up these soft and
cozy socks by going to
blazesocks.com that's
blazesocks.com today merry christmas
america where are my blaze socks they
didn't send me a pair of blaze socks i
want the let's go branded socks
okay let's talk about jen saki you guys
know i'm not a fan of gensake and
actually speaking of gensake if you want
to see the counterpart the complete
opposite of jen saki my interview with
kaylee mcinerney who is the former white
house press secretary under president
trump a guy who was trying to bring some
a woman sorry who was trying to bring
some truth uh in the face of a very
oppositional journalistic group of
people journalistic group people over
there uh part one is out today in the
full episode is already up at ruben
report.locals.com
but in any event jensaki was asked about
the federal judge who blocked joe
biden's vaccine requirement for federal
contractors and here's what she said why
does have any reaction to a federal
judge in georgia's decision to block the
administration from
enforcing the uh 2019 mandate vaccine
mandate for employees or
federal contractors
well the reason that we proposed
these
these requirements is that we know they
work
and we are confident in our ability
legally to make these happen across the
country
as you know the federal government the
largest employer in the country we have
successfully implemented these
requirements in a way that has not only
boosted vaccinations in the federal
government with more than ninety two
percent of people vaccinated but also
helps avoid disruptions and operations
uh and our implementation sends a clear
messages to businesses including federal
contractors that similar measures will
protect their workforce protect their
customers and protect our communities
i'd also note that a number of
businesses across the country have also
implemented these
requirements vaccinating or testing
requirements depending on the
organization and the ceo of lockheed
said last week that there are at
uh they are at over 95 on track to be
compliant and are well on their way to
be able to maintain operations so i
would just note of course
the department of justice will
vigorously defend uh this in court but
we know it works that's why the
president and the administration will
continue pressing forward
man i don't like that chick i mean first
off we know it works well what she's
saying there's we know that if we force
you to do something most people fall in
line just because you think you have the
power to do it and because a lot of
people are sheep doesn't mean it's good
it also depends what you mean by works
meaning it works that you force people
to get vaccinations that they need
another vaccination and another booster
and now omicron is coming and unicron
and again and again and again and again
so it works is a bit of a
you're being a little sloppy there uh
but the line really we are confident in
our ability legally to make these
happen across the country uh no lady a
federal judge just said no she's saying
we're confident in our ability legally
no the federal judge you know
saki if you're watching i don't know if
you know this what you do as a press
secretary is you lie right so the
administration comes in they tell you
can you message our [ __ ] and we want
to force people to do things that are
unconstitutional because we do have a
right to privacy you have a right to
choice right okay we these are things
we've had in america for a long time but
joe or who's ever pulling joe's puppet
strings says saki you've got to tell
people that we're doing this thing so
they come in with this ridiculous
mandate right she says it's legal the
judge then says and judges are the ones
who decide what's legal judges they do
this crazy thing they get a lot of
papers in front of them it's nuts i've
got papers here too they get papers and
they look at what the law says and then
they analyze the law and then they
debate it with other judges and then it
goes through the courts and we have
lower level courts and we have circuit
courts and sometimes jen things move all
the way up to the supreme court and
those are the ultimate deciders of what
is legal or not you you soulless freak
are not a legal expert so just because
you say it's legal well a judge a
federal judge
just said it ain't and people are sick
of your [ __ ] and i think we are
getting to a tipping point i think
people have had it with these people i i
talked to a lot of people yesterday and
i know what who i talk to may be
somewhat self-selecting and all of that
but
i think people are sick of the mandates
altogether even the people who were
going along with it the entire time are
now going wait a minute wait a minute i
did i did my uh shot i did my second
shot i did my booster now fauci and the
rest of them are saying oh this doesn't
even count as fully vaccinated and why
isn't the country fully open and why am
i still showing a passport and why do
they still want me wearing a mask so you
know what fouchy you know what sake you
know what biden keep pushing keep
pushing at this point keep going keep
going keep going because we've got
midterms coming and i think you guys are
in for a wake-up call that is going to
be
rather extraordinary but if you don't
think sake is bad enough herself
and i had to debate this morning whether
i was going to show this clip because
you know my policy i'm trying to only
show you the the good clips about kobet
and i thought that showing again that
she's lying as it comes to dealing with
the vaccinations i thought that was a
positive one but then we saw this clip
this morning this is uh fouchy over on
uh andrea mitchell's show on msnbc and
again it's very important to me that you
guys when you're watching msnbc you must
keep in mind these people are
broadcasting from a mental institution
they're not well they don't know what's
going on they have a complete psychotic
break from reality anyway andrea
mitchell
asked fauci about the mandates and
listen to what he says and tell me if
you think he's a good guy or a bad guy
there's so much opposition now in
congress and across the states even in
democratic states
governor whitmer and michigan and other
places this becoming just a political
chest and the outlook in
the outlook is not at all a sure thing
in the court system
is there any thought of backing off of
that
and trying to avoid
you know
all the outcry against it
yeah but you know andrew we we really
have to get people vaccinated i mean i
understand and we all understand
how people do not like to be told what
to do they want to make their own choice
and their own free will i get that and i
respect that but these are unusual times
and you can't think only of yourself and
your own personal opinion but you've got
to think about your communal
responsibility to get yourself in your
family and indirectly then the community
protected so i would prefer and we all
would prefer that people would be
voluntarily getting vaccinated
but if they're not going to do that
sometimes you've got to do things that
are unpopular but that clearly supersede
individual choices
and are directed predominantly at the
communal good and that's what we're
talking about when we're talking about
requirements
he is not a good man i anthony fauci is
a collectivist he is basically a
communist marxist whatever you want to
call them at this point that you have to
put aside what you think you have to put
aside the autonomy over your body and
your mind why do you have to do it for
the common good
well it seems he might have dropped the
ball on the common good seeing as we're
two years into this thing and he's been
in charge the entire time and if the
vaccines worked i know
no i'm not a scientist
i'm not
if the vaccines worked then if you were
vaccinated and a crazy right-wing white
supremacist lunatic who was unvaccinated
walked past you it wouldn't matter
because you were vaccinated
but they don't even believe in the
vaccinations and they don't even
and they don't believe in the
constitution that's very obvious and
everything he's saying there is
antithetical to everything that the
united states is founded upon by the way
anthony fauci has no power over you do
you know that like yeah he's the head of
the nih he's allowed to make
recommendations and he's allowed to spew
his nonsense on propaganda networks but
he can't force you to do anything yet i
don't know how long that will that will
last i mean the clock is running out
here but this is what i mean and when i
played this clip within the context of
that it's positive it's like enough
enough i've just had enough and i don't
think i'm the only one i've had enough
of this person listening to him as if he
has any right or
it's not even any right i know he has no
right to tell me what to do but at this
point if you give him any
uh of your respect when it comes to any
of this you're making a serious serious
mistake uh sometimes you've got to give
up in essence your rights for the
communal good
sometimes you know you shouldn't say
what you think sometimes you shouldn't
do what you think is right you should
just leave it up to unelected
bureaucrats that's what you should do
that's what you should do
or don't that's the positive part or
don't
uh all right guys the third story uh you
know robert e lee he was the leader of
the confederate army it's a part of our
history that we had a civil war uh well
charlottesville virginia which obviously
a couple years ago there was the
incident in charlottesville with actual
white supremacists who were chanting and
marching through charlottesville and it
was all because they were going to take
down a statue of robert e lee
and
now they are going to take down a statue
of robert e lee in charlottesville and
they're going to melt it and turn it
into a social justice thingamajig we've
got a quote here from the newspaper that
is now known as the new york times but
it's really not a newspaper but we went
with the new york times because i'm
trying to be nice i'm trying to be you
know give you a plurality of opinions
around here the city council of
charlottesville virginia voted on
tuesday to donate a statue of robert e
lee to an african-american heritage
center that plans to melt the bronze
monument the focus of a deadly white
nationalist rally in 2017 into material
for a new piece of public art the 4-0
vote by the council followed years of
debate over the fate of the statue four
years ago a plan to remove the statute
drew scores of white nationalists to
charlottesville for a unite the right
rally that led to violence including the
killing of a counter-protester by an
ohio man who plowed a car into a crowd
after taking it down the city accepted
proposals from bidders who wanted the
lee statue and a nearby statue of
stonewall jackson another confederate
general that was also removed so okay so
let's back up because this is a this is
a big thing
this was one of the key moments over the
last couple years charlottesville very
fine people on both sides
white supremacists like the whole thing
right it all boiled down over the last
couple years in some ways to this very
moment in charlottesville so what
they're going to do now is they're going
to take that statue they're going to
melt it they'll turn it into some social
justice thing i don't know a george
floyd memorial or okay whatever they're
going to do now that's i suppose the
city council's choice and if that's what
they're going to do that's what they're
going to do now as i always say with
these statue removal stories it's like
does any of this make us more tolerant
does anyone feel that we are becoming a
more tolerant a more open society
because of any of this are we turning to
our neighbor and looking at that
neighbor and giving them the benefit of
the doubt because of any of this or is
it making us actually more polarized is
it oddly making everything more racist
have we unearthed some stuff that we had
put down for a long time i think the
answer to that is probably yes but the
reason i wanted to do this story is not
so much that they're going to melt this
thing and turn it into some weird social
justice statute that's just fine if so
they choose
but
this is the moment that really broke a
lot of people when you talk about trump
breaking people and the media lying
about everything so now i'm going to
show you the video right after the
charlottesville incident this is donald
trump talking about the white
supremacists
talking about canceling historical
figures and talking about very fine
people on both sides and you just see
for yourself if this video is the way
that it's framed when you hear about
this on mainstream media but you also
had people that were
very fine people on both sides
you had people in that group excuse me
excuse me i saw the same pictures as you
did you had people in that group that
were there to protest the taking down of
to them a very very important statue and
the renaming of a park from robert e lee
to another name
george washington was a slave owner was
george washington a slave owner
so will george washington now lose his
status are we going to take down excuse
me are we going to take down are we
going to take down statues to george
white
how about thomas jefferson what do you
think of thomas jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner
now we're going to take down his statue
so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
and you had people and i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
nationalists because they should be
condemned totally
did you get the last three seconds of
that he absolutely and his words totally
condemns the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists when he's talking about
very fine people on both sides he is
talking about very fine people on both
sides of whether you should take down
these statues because if you take down a
robert e lee statue
as he points out well then you're going
to have to take down george washington
statues and you're going to have to take
down thomas jefferson statues which of
course that is what the woke
progressives are coming to do now what's
interesting about that clip and i know
you guys know this because you watch
this show and you're not brainwashed you
know npc blue check buffoons
he did do that and it's been debunked a
gazillion times but most people don't
know that most people don't know that
right after he said very fine people on
both sides which became a rallying cry
for the left in mainstream media that
donald trump is is a racist and a white
supremacist even though he
condemned them just seconds later which
they never show that became a rallying
card what most people don't know is that
moment of trump right there
that is why joe biden said he was
running for president so now we're going
to show you a minute of joe biden's
campaign launch video and this is
actually quite extraordinary i wish
other people in mainstream media would
cover this sort of thing because joe
biden decided to run for president
because of charlottesville that's
exactly what he said and this is a
minute of his campaign ad take a look
it was there in august of 2017 we saw
klansmen and white supremacists and
neo-nazis come out in the open
their crazed faces
illuminated by torches veins bulging and
burying the fangs of racism
chanting the same anti-semitic bile
heard across europe in the 30s
and they were met by a courageous group
of americans
in a violent clash ensued
and a brave young woman lost her life
and that's when we heard the words of
the present united states that stunned
the world and shocked the conscience of
this nation
he said there were quote
some very fine people on both sides
very fine people on both sides
you see what he did right there
you see what he did so just know that
joe biden in his campaign launch video
where he talks about the reason that he
got back into politics after stepping
away for four years was because trump
was racist
trump was basically a white supremacist
trump did not condemn white supremacists
and neo-nazis and i just show you the
video that he did i don't even mean to
make this all about trump
but this is what it's all about we are
being fed lies
and lies and lies and more lies and
until people are woken up from those
lies it is just
going to
continue it just ain't gonna stop so joe
biden launched his campaign on a lie are
you a biden supporter may want to think
about that may want to think about that
all right guys we have one more for you
which is actually directly related to
all of this and i think will be a nice
way to to button the show uh you know
yesterday i showed you a video of a 92
year old holocaust survivor who survived
auschwitz that was really the most
brutal of all the concentration camps um
and talking about how this stuff the
creeping side of authoritarianism how it
happens incrementally first you sort of
talk about those people in that certain
way those people are diseased those
people are dirty those people are greedy
those people are evil then you say those
people shouldn't be on those benches
because there's other benches they can
be on and they shouldn't be at our
schools because they can have their own
schools and they shouldn't go on these
buses and they shouldn't go into these
theaters maybe they shouldn't shop at
the same hours as often us and the
series of things that happen slowly
because now it's very strange what's
happened to all of us in the last two
years if you would have asked most
people two years ago like how did the
nazis come to power how could something
so obviously evil
come to power
most people really wouldn't know you
wouldn't really understand yeah you
could read it in a textbook and you
could go oh there was this guy hitler
and he was this really great speaker and
germany was really upset after world war
one and they were economically depressed
and they needed a scapegoat and you can
sort of intellectualize it at some level
but how does that
get you to oh we're going to exterminate
six million of our people we're going to
launch a war and millions and millions
of russians are going to be killed and
we're going to rampage across europe and
all of those things and how do you turn
citizen against citizen and make people
that were neighbors next thing you know
literally shooting their neighbors and
having them dig their own ditches and
all the
extraordinary horrors that are almost
too crazy to mention right has it
happened well i think if you asked most
people two years ago they would have
given you some intellectual version of
it where in the last two years i think
we all kind of see it at this point you
can kind of see it you can kind of see
how for two years you would demonize
demonize
those people shouldn't go on planes
happening in canada right now those
people shouldn't go on trains happening
in canada right now those people should
be put in quarantine camps special camps
for them happening in australia right
now
those people shouldn't be able to go
into certain stores without showing
their papers happening in new york city
right now happening in los angeles right
now so the slow creep of these things
is i think showing us something very
very evil but very important to know
about human nature anyway yesterday i
saw a clip of jordan peterson on joe
rogan's show this is from about four
years ago so this is before
uh obviously before covid and all that
before lockdowns before masks and all
that it's also right at the beginning of
when jordan was sort of catching on and
one of the things that i find so
interesting about it is is when you see
someone from years ago that was talking
about things that are now so relevant so
with all that in mind here's a quick
clip of jordan talking about the warning
signs and how things can get much worse
before you even know it things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if i encroach i if i encroach
on you and i'm sophisticated about it
i'm going to encroach two millimeters
i'm going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then i'm
going to stop then i'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then i'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then i'm gonna
stop then i'm gonna wait and i'm just
gonna do that forever and before you
know it you're gonna be back three miles
from where you started and you'll have
done it one step at a time and then
you'll go oh how'd i get here and the
answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called ordinary men by
robert browning
i actually ordered ordinary men last
night
so i will read the book and and
hopefully i can
share some more of those ideas with you
but does that sound
familiar does that kinda sound like
what's happening right now
do you think history repeats itself do
you think human nature is what it is and
nazis just don't miraculously show up
like that do you think you slowly
dehumanize people do you think you
slowly otherwise people and next thing
you know good people are doing horrible
things
good people are ratting on their
neighbors good people are assaulting
people because they're not wearing masks
etc etc could it all actually be
happening right now
i don't know what do you think let me
know
uh a couple comments from the locals
community throughout the show mark says
uh did elon get into a fight with a
barber because he lost yeah i don't know
what's going on there it's you know i
appreciate the the short sides and the
longer top i've been rocking it for a
long time i'm a little long on the sides
right now but he's going full on like
crazy mode there mop up top uh let's say
uh peter says dave is making my cat
libertarian i feel like all cats are
libertarian cats cats don't like rules
cats want to do what cats are anarchists
actually and a cat i don't like cats you
guys know my feelings on cats i don't
like house i'm allergic to cats
never have liked cats but i've had
friends with cats and i don't i you know
i try not to go to their houses too
often because i can't breathe but you
know a cat will always be looking at you
in the distance like it's about to kill
you i like a dog you know they come up
to you they think about you they want to
be scratched they want you know they
want to play with you they want to lay
on you they want to play fetch that's a
pleasant animal the cat thing i just
don't get it but you know what i don't
want to i don't want to otherize or
demonize cat people so if you are a cat
person tell me why maybe i need to
become a little more tolerant towards
cats so please tell us uh in the reuben
report community that's where i check
most of the comments uh hank says you
know i think fauci missed his calling as
a bond villain man
he is a bond villain and he's not even
that good of a bond villain because he's
so transparent you know ah it's just
absolutely terrible uh guys part one of
my interview with kaylee mcinany former
white house press secretary is up right
now on youtube
and the full thing of course is up early
and ad free at rubinreport.locals.com
tomorrow is a round table no tomorrow's
not a roundtable today's wednesday
tomorrow is a regular show it's a q a as
we always do you get your questions
submitted right now at report.locals.com
and then our friday show is the round
table we've got matt ridley elijah
shaffer and jake maquette
and i have to say people i i promised a
lot today you know at the top of the
show i said it was going to be a primo
show and if it was not for my mistake
just 10 seconds ago
you know thinking that tomorrow is
friday for just this sheer moment i
would have said absolute flawless a plus
perfection
are you going to grant me a little
leeway on that one you know what i mean
like i got the day wrong i'm looking at
the guest panel
that's for you to decide let us know in
the comments good seeing you everybody
more tomorrow adios
you